hey guys this is Vadim with max tech
welcome to another video a lot of you
guys have been asking me to compare the
2020 I pad pro right here versus the
2020 MacBook Air and that's because a
lot of people are looking for a good
laptop replacement which the iPad pro is
especially now with cursive support as
you guys can see I've got my Magic Mouse
2 right here and I'm having this cursor
I'm able to right-click I'm able to
swipe a lot of things it's very very
convenient right here on this iPad pro
so this is obviously not the best way to
use cursor support on an iPad pro Apple
is actually coming out with their new
magic keyboard case in May it's going to
be packin a trackpad so this cursor
support is gonna be working perfectly
and it also has passed through charging
which means you can plug in your cable
into the case and that's going to be
able to charge up your iPad pro leaving
your regular USB C port alone so you can
use it for other things like
transferring files the only downside is
that is very expensive $300 for the
keyboard case alone now with the entire
iPad pro setup it looks like it's going
to be an easy buy over the MacBook Air
however this is the new 2020 MacBook Air
and Apple has actually made it a really
good deal they've lowered the price by
$100 so now it's $1000 but it also comes
with double the storage 256 gigs a
storage on the 20/20 MacBook Air now
this is the 11 inch 2020 iPad pro which
starts at eight hundred dollars and has
double the storage compared to last year
but it's only 128 compared to 256 on the
MacBook Air and of course you're also
gonna want to buy a keyboard case with
the iPad pro to make it a laptop
replacement now here we have the Bridge
Pro keyboard case which you can find on
Amazon for a hundred dollars or a
hundred fifty
it is to put the iPad pro into the
Bridge Pro you basically just slide it
into these hinges just like that and now
look you could open it up and the
benefit of this is that you have full
adjustability from 0 to 180 degrees we
also have Apple's smart keyboard case
this is for the 2018 model as you can
see it doesn't have the square bump like
on the 22
model but we actually prefer the bridge
because you get that adjustability
now this keyboard case does not come
with a trackpad but bridge is actually
working on their Pro Plus keyboard that
does come with the trackpad and it's
going to be available next month for two
hundred and thirty dollars so that'll
bring the price of this iPad pro set up
to over a thousand dollars but we
honestly think that Apple's upcoming
magic keyboard case is the better Buy
and that's three hundred dollars so
that'll make it eleven hundred dollars
for this iPad pro set up
now this twenty twenty MacBook Air is
actually the quad core i5 model which we
recommend for almost everybody and that
brings a price up to eleven hundred
dollars so it's matching with both of
these setups now if you want to learn
why we recommend the quad core i5 model
make sure to check out that video after
this video is over now we totally agree
that the twelve point nine inch model of
the 20/20 iPad pro is a much better
comparison to the 13-inch MacBook Air
but for now we just have the eleven inch
in our office and if you get the twelve
point nine inch set up that's actually a
thousand three hundred and fifty dollars
with apples magic keyboard so before we
get into comparing these software and
functionality differences between these
two devices
let's first compare some of the smaller
differences now the iPad pro by itself
weighs a little bit over a pound but
when you're combining it with a bridge
pro keyboard is actually somewhere near
the weight of the MacBook Air maybe not
as heavy but it's definitely pretty
close and of course if you're using
Apple's smart keyboard the weight is
gonna go down on the iPad pro set up and
I think Apple's upcoming magic keyboard
should weigh less than the bridge pro as
well now closing both of these we can
see that they both are around the same
thickness pretty close at the thickest
part but of course the MacBook Air is
thinner near the front and if we put the
iPad pro set up on top of the MacBook
Air we can see just how much more
portable it is than the MacBook now
comparing the ports the MacBook Air
actually gets a headphone jack which you
don't get on the 20/20 iPad pro you're
gonna have to use an adapter or use the
USB C port this also has two fundable
three ports on the MacBook Air which
support much faster transfer speeds than
regular u.s. PC you can connect some
pretty awesome
drives and devices using Thunderbolt 3
and on the iPad pro we just have a
single USBC port right here and the
bridge pro has a u.s. PC port for
charging but that's just for the
keyboard case itself now the iPad pro
has speakers on the top and on the
bottom so you get stereo sound just like
you get on the macbook air which will be
comparing the sound quality of both of
these in just a minute the cool thing
about the iPad pro is that you get rear
cameras which you obviously don't get on
the MacBook Air you get a main 12
megapixel lens in an ultra wide 10
megapixel which we compared to the 2018
iPad pro in our previous video so we
check that out and the ultra wide
actually looks really good so if you're
interested in watching that video make
sure to watch that after this one's over
the iPad pro also gets a brand new lidar
scanner which you obviously don't get on
the MacBook Air and what it does is it
greatly improves the depth sensing which
is really useful for augmented reality
which we tested and it works pretty
great and the iPad pro gets a much
better 7 megapixel selfie camera
compared to 1.2 megapixels on the
MacBook Air so let's compare the video
quality and the microphone quality this
is a video and audio quality test on the
2020 MacBook Air this is a video and
audio quality test on the 2020 iPad pro
next up let's compare the displays and
it might look funny with the MacBook Air
like this but from the top down view you
can see that the size of the 13-inch
MacBook Airs display is quite a bit
larger than the 11 inch so that's a
pretty big advantage of course you have
the option of getting the 12 point 9
inch with the iPad pro now let's compare
the maximum brightness on both of these
as you can see the MacBook Air is all
the way up and same with the iPad pro
and you can see that the iPad pros
display is a lot brighter than on the
MacBook Air along with the extra
brightness the iPad pro actually has p-3
wide color gamut support so it's
actually going to be showing more colors
than on the MacBook Air so YouTube
videos streaming other videos like
Netflix is going to look much better on
the iPad pro and you can actually see
the difference in this p3 color test
they're both trying to display p3 but
the MacBook Air can't show the image in
the center of the screen because it
doesn't support the extra shades of
color now another big benefit of the
iPad pro is that it has promotion to
which means the display can refresh up
to a hundred and twenty Hertz and
dynamically go down to 24 Hertz when
you're watching a video that was filmed
at 24 fps and of course the MacBook Air
just has a standard 60 Hertz display so
the iPad pro wins by far in the display
department and obviously the iPad pro
has a touch screen so you can
conveniently take it out of the case and
use it in tablet mode take it on the
couch or wherever you'd like and the
iPad pro also supports the
second-generation Apple pencil so you
could do some note-taking you do some
drawing you can sign a documents very
easily and use professional apps with
this as well and the cool thing about
the iPad pro is that it comes with face
ID authentication just like on your
recent iPhones you just tap swipe up
like that and you're in compared to the
MacBook Air has the touch ID sensor so I
totally prefer face ID over touch ID and
what's nice about the new cursor support
is that you don't even have to touch
your iPad you just click move it around
and just swipe up like that and you're
in without even touching the iPad now
let's get into our speaker comparison
between the 20/20 iPad pro and the 20/20
MacBook Air
[Music]
[Music]
so as you just heard you get much better
speakers with a 2020 MacBook Air
obviously there's a lot more room for
the speakers so now let's compare the
performance between these two one key
differences at the MacBook Air gets 8
gigabytes of RAM compared to 6 on the
20/20 iPad pro let's start off with the
CPU test and Geekbench 5 so we've got
our CPU results right here we have a
thousand 116 for the single core on the
iPad pro compared to a thousand 170 so
you're getting better single core
performance on the MacBook Air but if we
look at multi-core we have four thousand
six hundred and forty on the iPad pro
compared to three thousand and forty
seven so you're actually getting much
better multi-core performance on the
iPad pro which is pretty awesome because
it's that small of a device now let's
compare the graphics performance using
the metal test here are the results we
have nine thousand eight hundred and
thirty five on the iPad pro and 9018 on
the MacBook Air
now this score on the MacBook Air has
actually improved quite a bit since the
2019 model used to be around 3,000 3,500
and now it's 9000 so that's a huge boost
both the 20/20 iPad pro is still faster
for graphics related tasks a nice spec
update for the MacBook Air is that it
finally has bluetooth 5 which the iPad
pro has had since the 2018 model I think
but the iPad pro now has Wi-Fi 6
compared to the older 802 11 AC Wi-Fi so
that's going to give you a more reliable
and faster connection to the Internet
and on the plus side you also have the
option of getting a LTE connected iPad
pro which you can't do with the MacBook
Air now I want to talk about the
keyboards the 2020 MacBook Air has the
new magic keyboard straight from the 16
inch MacBook Pro and honestly I love
these keys so much better than the
butterfly they're more reliable they
feel a lot better you get more key
travel now obviously with the iPad pro
we have the bridge Pro keyboard and
these are pretty similar but they're a
little bit mushy they honestly don't
feel as good but I think Apple's
upcoming magic keyboard is gonna have
the same scissor switch keys that are
coming on this MacBook Air the only
difference is that because the iPad pro
is not as wide the keys are going to be
kind of
grunts together a little bit so you're
gonna be having a better typing
experience on this MacBook Air another
cool thing with this MacBook is that the
trackpad is actually a force touch
trackpad that means it doesn't actually
move it has a motor underneath it so
when you're touching it it just vibrates
to simulate a click this is honestly the
best trackpad that I've ever used Mac
books always have the best trackpads
compared to Windows laptops now let's
finally get into the biggest difference
between these two which is software
support of course the iPad pro has the
brand-new cursive support which is
really really awesome this means you can
now wake up your iPad without even
touching it you can right click on apps
and items you can drag and drop you can
swipe up and down to scroll you can
change all of your settings like the
volume and the brightness you can
accurately edit text and even do some
photo editing without ever touching the
display however I still think that the
cursor software is better on the MacBook
Air you get better file management you
get better drag-and-drop you get better
multitasking compared to the iPad pro
Apple has been doing this for years
compared to the brand new cursor support
on the iPad but I'd say the biggest
difference between these two is that the
macbook air supports apps that you
cannot get on the iPad pro we're talking
Logic Pro 10 we're talking Xcode 4
programing Final Cut Pro 4 video editing
and other apps like that of course there
are some alternatives on the iPad pro
but they're just not the same
so if you need one of those professional
apps that I mentioned you're obviously
going to be going with the MacBook Air
because you can't get them on the iPad
but A+ for the iPad is that it's now
getting better software support with
updated apps like full Photoshop full
Lightroom you get Microsoft Word Excel
PowerPoint so it's nice to see that
we're getting better apps on the iPad
now the biggest benefit for the iPad in
terms of software is that you have
access to the massive iOS app store that
means you get thousands of apps and a
very large selection of games that you
simply can't get on the MacBook Air now
in terms of web browsing the iPad pro
actually does as good of a job as the
MacBook Air especially now that it gets
the cursor support you can easily
swipe up swipe down browse the web
right-click everything that you can do
on the MacBook Air so now with all of
those things that we compared into
consideration which one do you buy in
2022 you buy the 20/20 iPad pro or the
20/20 MacBook Air honestly if you just
need one of these devices for common
computing tasks like let's say web
browsing video streaming watching
YouTube watching Netflix using regular
apps like Microsoft Word Excel and other
simple stuff like that then either of
these will work perfectly fine for you
the MacBook Air is more for people who
need to do a little bit more like using
those professional apps that I mentioned
but if you don't need that I'd say that
the iPad pro is actually the better
choice because you get a lot of other
advantages like being able to use the
Apple pencil having a much better 120
Hertz display being able to use it in
tablet mode getting access to a lot more
games having better cameras and
microphones and of course the new lidar
scanner for augmented reality so I would
say that there has honestly never been a
better time to buy an iPad pro even with
the 20/20 MacBook Air being such a good
deal now if you're still confused about
which one of these devices to buy let us
know your specific situation down below
in the comments and we'll help you out
make sure to tap that like button click
the circle above to subscribe and check
out one of those two videos that I
mentioned right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]